folks Joe D Rosa here I am out on the
road doing those live shows all over the
place and uh let's folks Jo de R Roa
here I am out doing live shows all over
the place by myself not with the Pod
just alone solo doing my thing uh first
up November 9th New York New York I'm
doing a special show this is a a
selected readings I'm going to be
reading entries for my audio book the
penous papers so plus plus some other
stuff I've had published over the years
uh that's for the New York comedy
Festival in New York New York at the KGB
bar on November 9th November 11th
Philadelphia PA theater of the Living
Arts almost sold out only a few tickets
left please come out to that November
17th we're sold out Pittsburgh PA at the
bottle rocket November 18th Buffalo New
York theater at senica 1 again almost
sold out buy your tickets Please
November 30th Denver Colorado at the
summit December 1st Phoenix Arizona at
the Crescent Ballroom December 3rd Salt
Lake City in Utah at the soundwell and
January 13th just announced New York New
York gramar SE theater folks new hour
popping off at the grammar seat and all
of those other venues I just listed with
the exception of the KGB bar show that's
the only one that's not me doing I never
Promise You a Rose Garden I'm going to
be doing readings from the book at that
show and that show only Anyway come
check me out joder rosa.com for all the
show info and your ticket links and as
usual if you're in New York please
please please come us at Joey roses open
7 days a week at 11:30 a.m. every day
delicious sandwiches cheap drinks come
see us and if you want info about the
venue Joey roses nc.com
taste the they they like two going to
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man hey folks welcome to t a
s e buds we got a not a special guest
but a guest
uh Ian fance is here yes how are you
buddy I'm great man it's good to see you
I break your I bust your Stones cuz
you're a friend yes but um you know uh I
I do love you thank you you're welcome
friends bust each other's Stones yeah
that is the end of the day it's all love
it's all sign of Allah what did they
used to say on the friar things we only
roast roast the ones we love yes and
speaking of love you guys are going to
love going to my special taping Sunday
December 3rd New York City The Cutting
Room two shows 7 and 9:30 eian
finance.com you're going to try to fill
that room twice that's ballsy
the speaking of ballsy you've started to
love smacking them around how's that
feel Joe very good yeah I like yeah I
know right I like it yeah I love a good
sack I think it should make the
the yeah yeah should make that noise
when oh yeah um we have another guest uh
supposedly coming
um you know this guy's always late is he
really oh yeah when we're on the road
it's ticktock tick tock wait for this
guy to stop playing with this now he
said to don't say the street because I
don't want to give our location away but
he said uh he said that he got off at at
uh 12:02 he said that he got off at the
stop that V says is two blocks
away
um in his defense it's a little bit Nar
down there what do you mean Narnia like
hard to find yeah figure it out life's
hard be harder what the we doing here
also maybe give yourself a little extra
time to to get to the place yeah and now
I'm throwing stones and I'm glass house
cuz I'm laate a lot well but I'm on a
I'm on a tight turnaround today yeah
you've got to do more mixing for salsa
ver day or whatever the hell your little
no side project is today this is going
to come out after the live show but but
when's that well the live show was
October 28th at AR's grocery but today
is the F oh look who decided to show up
oh hello
sunglasses indoors Lou cats everybody
Lou good to see you wearing the same
shirt you always wear I'm so sorry to to
have put you out to be here for the
thing you asked to be on yeah such a
good energy just walking on just being
yell at that you were supposed to be
here a half hour ago well 12 not it was
not half an hour go 7 minutes ago 9 no
no 12:00 we said noon it's 1210 I'm a
few minutes late few minutes I'm a
couple minutes late start time well no a
couple's two 10 is 10 is yeah there you
go several minutes late you're on the
right track expensive amount late
unacceptable amount late none of those
things 10 no but but if you say start 's
at 12 it's at 12 yeah I've never seen a
podcast start on time congratulations
I'm being the only well this is the
first time you're doing on one that's
actually monetized itself and makes
money
you know I'm sorry uh maybe you're when
you're doing the the 1:00 a.m. slot at
gas digital you know last week was last
week was WTF it was Obama and then me so
I don't know I don't know I'm kind of
big time oh a war criminal and a late
Jew all right let's you so lucky to be
anywhere with Obama get out of here and
I'll say I you and I have something in
common we both love trans women cuz
Michelle's real name is Michael wait
were you did was Obama did you really
follow Obama last week on W Obama did it
in
2009 and this last week was the pickle
man or some [__] it was
Schwarzenegger but I was going to say I
was going to say you were late to Marin
I would have a I would literally have a
panic attack if I was late if I was late
meeting Marin for coffee I'd be hyper
late to to Marin I can't remember I'm
typically late always I Tred to be on
time this is pretty close to me this is
on time and I was really proud of myself
okay all right well whatever life like
he's in Spain we bust balls around here
we said before you showed up we only
roast the ones we love yeah you said
that wow yeah yeah we love you we other
Jeff Ross lines you got Alan King wow
was Alan King's line huh God who the
[__] is Alan King alen King and and
Freddy Roman were the were the were the
orig roers you're right right um Marin I
have a funny Marin story when I did WTF
um I was doing it to promote my special
at the time and uh I was so excited that
he was gonna have me on and I was also
like nervous I've known mark for a long
time but it you know it was a Big Show
and uh I was it was a I was doing it on
a Wednesday and the Wednesday before I
was doing it I was on my couch and I was
taking a nap and I woke up from the nap
and I looked at my phone and I had text
from Mark Maron and he goes what
happened buddy no I thought we were
we're not recording today I thought we
and I was like oh oh no oh no oh no oh
no so I look at my calendar and I I have
it in my calendar is the following
Wednesday and I call him he pick he's
like yeah and I because you know he sees
my name and I goes yeah and I go Mark if
I [__] up I'm really sorry but I have
it in my calendar as next week did I
make a mistake if I did this is I'm
really sorry but I want you to know I
didn't blow you off obviously and he
goes hold on let me check walks away
from the phone comes back 30 seconds
later and he goes okay so I guess I'm
the
idiot that's awesome yeah he goes I'll
see you next week and I was like all
right still angry at you for his mistake
I love that that's really really
beautiful and the inflection on I'm the
insinuation being I've been sitting here
calling you an idiot in my head for the
last
hour so I guess I'm the
idiot amazing that's great uh yeah was
funny and then I did the show and it was
really fun no he was he was good I'm
glad he brought me back it was he's a
cool guy he's cool to me so you've done
it twice yes okay so you can do it twice
I thought you were only allowed to do it
once some people all right
some hey are these should I leave these
on to different idiotic yeah are those
sunglasses or transition lenses
sunglasses they're sunglasses and I need
them to see so I they prescription
sunglasses yeah but why all cool out of
sunglasses cuz I just I need glasses so
I have to switch whole glasses in order
to you switched them when you got
indoors I was rushing to be on time
remember that part yeah but you were
already late pimp please highlight on
the shot of the most Jewish thing of all
time happening a man talking about how
he has to sh change his glasses as his
glass case falls out of his pocket of
his Woody Allen Army coat that he's
wearing dude one time I was handcuffed
in the back of a cop car and I it was
during Co I had a mask on and uh what
was this when you still drank no this
was dead ball sober I got arrested at
the airport for class 4 felony weapons
charge I got caught with brass I got
caught with brass and uncles at the
airport was it an accid stupid I forgot
I had him my one call in jail was to a t
to tell him I'm going to miss the first
kick in Utah cuz of brass knuckles you
might as well caught you with like ninja
stars or I forgot I had them the city's
crumbling everyone's getting assaulted
I'm a little guy I got to protect myself
how did you get out if you didn't call a
guy for bail huh how did you get out if
you didn't call a guy for bail catch and
release baby they lock you up for a
little and they give you a little
summons try to curse Les cuz Pimp's got
to be bleep Every curse really yeah yeah
why cuz there it's it's a whole thing
I'm not going to be a slave to the
algorithm bleep
slave can we do a thing where we bleep
to Rose's name every time we say it like
Trump yeah that'd be the best so so dude
I'm in the back of the cop car I'm
handcuffed and I got the mask on and uh
the cop is there's one driving to the
other and I go um excuse me can you fix
my glasses because they were fogging up
and they were like this cuz they had to
take everything off me to check me you
know and in my pocket they a man I'm
like wears wearing a mask yet carrying
brass knuckles I'm like no no I was in
the airp they made me put the mask on
they made me put the mask who made you
the Liberals
thek New York Police New York police
they made newk police I guess it was
different there than here cuz I never
saw a cop in a mask in New York the
Newark police made you put a Mas of all
the police forces I would have thought
you would have said the Portland Oregon
police putk on dude and also I'm I'm
like I'm not a threat you found the
found the brass knuckles in the same
pocket as a dut and a mustache comb like
what do we do I got news for you buddy
you look like a threat you do you look
like a problem yeah I'm just a Minor
Threat oh God you do look at your belt
look at what your yeah [__] you look
like a problem I'm serious sorry step to
me see what happens you step to me that
sounds like a threat yeah well you you
got to be tough in this
world you know anyway folks Louis was
with me when I got assaulted in a
graveyard yes I was over a mask over a
mask yes in a graveyard in a graveyard
next to the stress Factory I just
pictured never mind wait what why were
you in a graveyard at the stress Factory
he was SM texting or smoking it's right
around the corner from the stress factor
and I sitting outside the graveyard I'm
on the phone with my like years ago the
only place that feels lonier than the
stress factor is the graveyard next to
the stress
factor well dude me and this guy got
into it I'm on the phone with my chick
at the time and uh they walk away and
they threw a bottle at me and it [__]
it crashed sorry on on the ground next
to me and I get up I'm like you know a
lot of bad words a lot of female body
parts I'm calling them and uh they I go
you you want to throw some far away come
come and do it to my what are you
talking about get [__] over here it's
hard not to curse so they yeah so
they it so they called my bluff cuz I
had distance balls cuz I was like super
far away so I was like I can mou off
what are they going to do TR trudge all
the way back here and they did and the
guy came at me and I'm like is this a
joke like is this really happening and
the guy just speared me like Goldberg
and tackled me onto the concrete and I'm
like hitting him in the ribs and he's
just like bear hugging me and I'm like
kicking him off me and I like cut my
elbow my glasses and meanwhile I'm I got
my ex at the time in an earbud we were
breaking up getting back together and
literally before he tackles me I'm like
I can be the man that is there for you I
am there we will change and then she
hears me go ow ow ow stop stop no get
off so funny yeah and then Louis is my
lawyer going around like we need to find
the police I will tell them what to do
and and the cops like it's really he
said she said I go can you just put him
in a cop car and ruin his night at least
and let me stand behind you and like
talk s and uh they were like we can't
really do that yeah all right nothing
came of it well there you go so you're
not a
threat no I am a threat you got beat up
in a graveyard well I got some good
Wallops in it sounds like you got beat
up it does sound like well he did get a
little beat up that's how it sounded
right sometimes life beats you up what
are you going to do you fall down you
get back up you can take a
beating you you go Toe to Toe you better
pack a lunch we're going to be there all
day
uh today we're battling uh no today
we're battling uh Lou we did go with the
deli battle I think that was the right
move yeah we are battling Jewish deli
versus Italian deli which is the better
Deli um Ian and I are going to be team
uh Italian deli Louie is flying solo
with Jewish deli um I'm ready to go and
let me say before we start the battle
yes yes Ian and I both have great love
for the Jewish deli as I have love for
for Italian deli I I told him I said
dude I'll do Italian but I love je but
this is what this show is about this
show is is court it's not about whether
or not you hate the other thing it's not
about whether you think the other thing
is truly guilty it's about your thing
winning that's it it's about winning the
case so when we step into that battle
arena we go in yeah and that's it that's
how it works so no disrespect to the
Italian deli I love you but you're about
to go down I might wear a wife beater to
really embody the the Italian okay go
ahead cuz your head is
Jewish so I like that you're in between
the two my body to be
[Laughter]
Italian uh it's time to get salties yeah
yeah God we haven't done the chance in
Forever what's salty all right so we
have a chant to get us to get us amped
into into battle mode where here's
here's God you deserve to be stopped at
every airport I I wear my shirts like me
and D Roa like our women
tucked
so all right so the battle is here's the
thing the battle is uh I'm sorry the
salty is uh the chant is is you go it's
time to get salty it's time get salty
it's time get salty three times and then
you
launch as soon as you chant it three
times you launch an immediate insult at
the other
guy all right about the food or just
about about him personally and then you
do it again and then the other guy
launches one back at you that's it okay
but trust me it gets your juices going
all right all right let's do it so you
could one of us has to do it with Lou
and then Lou has to do it back to both
of us you want to do it to both of us I
defer to you since this is like your
thing okay all right ready what do I I
guess we go it's sun and get salty it's
time to get salty it's time to get salty
and then boom I just hit you immediately
with a fast insult all right and then we
do it again you can laugh I'm telling
you it'll get you going and then we do
it again and then you shoot one back at
me you're right we weren't laughing
enough naturally no not laughing no I'm
saying you'll he's laughing at the
concept like it doesn't work I'm saying
it works I'm saying it all right I mean
I don't know all right ready ready
yeah I think so on the count of three we
go it's time to get salty it's time to
get salty it's time to get salty I
insult you okay then we do it again and
then you insult me easy enough can I do
Ian if you want to but I'm going to
insult you yeah you do easy I'm too easy
no it be funny it'll be around the ready
all right going around yeah I'll do you
and then you do me and then we'll start
ready folks let's talk about butcher box
who doesn't love butcher box everybody
loves but we love butcher box box uh why
do we love butcher box well cuz they're
providing high quality meat and it's
easy to find and it's easy to trust you
know you're getting your quality and
your money's worth and a great deal when
you're shopping with busher box when it
comes to your meats and your Seafoods
there's no better way to go it's 100%
grass-fed be beef there's Freer range
organic chicken there's pork that's
raised crate free and the seafood is
wild caught it's all humanely raised no
antibiotics no added hormones none of
that stuff it's delivered right to your
doorstep free shipping always amazing
and it's curated uh in customized box
plant uh there's a variety of high
quality Cuts uh of meats and things at
an amazing value there's exclusive
member deals and uh you know they they
also offer you uh recipe inspiration and
guides and tips and and all kinds of
good stuff so you're so you're doing the
best stuff possible with that meat that
you're getting I love meat I love
butcher box I think uh their options and
their deals are unbeatable especially
when you're even comparing it to your
local grocery store that's the thing a
lot of online services it's kind of like
well you got to pay a little extra to do
this thing but at least I don't have to
go to that butcher box is giving you the
convenience of online and then also in
in my opinion beating the grocery store
prices that you're getting uh as far as
the quality and stuff that you're
finding through them and through their
products uh I love butcher box anyway
this Black Friday your search for
amazing deals on high quality and
protein
ends with butcher box that's right your
search ends with butcher box meaning
they're going to give it to you they're
offering their best deal of the Year
choose your free steak for a
year okay choose between two New York
strip steaks fet Manan or ribey to get
free in every box for a whole year when
you join sign up today at butcherbox /
tastebuds and use code tastebuds you're
going to choose your free steak for a
year and you're going to get $20 off
that's butcherbox.com tastebuds use code
tastebuds to get this special Black
Friday deal plus $20 off folks let's
talk about game time a regular sponsor
here at the tastebuds podcast if you
like to go see live events but you don't
always have the ability to buy those
tickets far in advance for whatever your
reason is game time is the app free for
you why cuz you shouldn't have to worry
when you buy tickets for a big event
game time is providing a fast and easy
way to buy tickets for all sports music
comedy and Theater events near you with
killer last minute deals Allin prices
views from your seat and the best price
guaranteed game time takes the guesswork
out of buying tickets uh it's easy to
find the tickets on the app uh it's easy
to find the events on the app that
you're looking for tickets for and my
favorite feature is the seat views that
you can see what it's going to look like
from your seat wherever you're sitting
wherever you're buying the ticket for
wherever you're sitting in the venue
anyway I want you to try game time today
take the guest workout of buying tickets
with game time you're going to download
that app you're going to create an
account and use code taste buds to get
$20 off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account and redeem code
taste buds t a s bu U DS for $20 off
download game time today last minute
ticket it's lowest price
guaranteed ready 1 2 3 it's time to get
salty it's time to get salty it's time
to get salty your head's too small
especially when your gut is so
big oh wow I work out oh do you no it
ain't working out
yeah yeah the only workout you're doing
is with a sandwich feel that feel that
when you went oh wow see that's what I'm
talking about get that fire in your
sorry guess dead fire your belly angry
and upset now that's good all right yeah
let's go insult him now no he insulted
you insult him no salty all P do it come
on momentum go 1 2 3 it's time to get
salty time to get salty time to get
salty you're a weak little man no he's
insulting you oh it's time to get salty
it's time to get salty it's time to get
Sal salty you're only funny when you're
loud whoa whoa all right time two B A TT
l e buds here we go Jewish deli versus
Italian deli first of all I am so happy
to be on the side of Italian deli you
know why cuz ain't nobody from a Jewish
deli going to beat me up for [__] on
it Italian deli you [__] on the Italian
deli you got a you got a problem on your
hands you got to what's the point of
that to get you where you're at I was in
a better place before when you when you
[__] on a I can be funny softer no you
can't you just when
you [__] I when you [__] on an Italian
deli you got a bunch of Gottis on your
hands afterwards it's no good when you
[__] on a Jewish deli what's going to
happen what are they going to come count
my
money oh my god wow
what what is that is that a bad joke to
make right now in this climate I'm sorry
I'm just joking it is I thought you were
monetized I guess you're not anymore
sorry yeah well of course he's worried
about the
money that wasn't loud I didn't mean I
didn't mean that as the as the like
greedy thing I meant it as like like
they're they they're like smart like
nerdy yeah yeah we are smart and so
smart that we decided to put tables and
chairs in our delies and turn it into a
restaurant whereas Italian delies are
just counters you can't even think
beyond the concept go back to the greedy
stereotype greedy it's a restaurant with
all sorts of things in there all you got
is hams and hams and hams and hams on
hams and that's it dude listen to me
listen to me to quote the Great
Sebastian meniscal oh exactly to quote
him I yes do it in the voice he said the
funniest thing he said this to me at a
party in the voice in montre I will he
said this to to me at a in the corner of
a party in Montreal I was talking to him
and Pete Corelli it was when he was
engaged to marry his wife who is Jewish
or or half Jewish I think she's Jewish
yeah uh and I said to him I go I go
that's awesome dude cuz you're Italian
and now you're marrying into Jewish I go
you're getting the the best of all qu uh
of all Cuisines I go you get to get the
Jewish Cuisine now too and he goes their
entire menu falls apart after breakfast
that is
preposterous that is preposterous I
can't believe that their entire menu
falls apart after breakfast he said it
he said it went as far as locks and
bagels he's having pami for breakfast
he's having I'm get out of here list let
me tell you about pastrami pami is tell
me how delicious it is pami tastes like
corn beef amazing pastrami tastes a lot
of the time like hot dogs it tastes like
chopped up hot dog delicious hot dogs
are but do you want a hot dog do you
want a chopped up sandwich of hot dog
meat that's what pami tastes like crazy
it's not crazy that is crazy it tastes
just like that has so much more depth
than the other Italian meats you get an
Italian sub it's just a salt bomb it's
just a salt explos your mouth pami is
sweet it's peppery and it's salty it's
got all the flavor levels it's not sweet
sweet Peppers Peppers salt goes on an
Italian sub what are you talking
about dude you guys got one listen guts
enormous I'm going to you guys got I'm
in better shape than you Ian come on are
you insane no I'm not that's nut not not
nut you couldn't do 20 push-ups right
now have you seen the guns have you seen
the guns what are you talking about
those are good gun in better shape you
are a shape I'm in better shape I'm in
better shape do 25 push-ups right now
Focus no no no no no new new argument
who's in better
shape are you kidding me right now I'm a
brick [__] house Louie you got half that
right Louie yeah there you go he got you
good shut up this is your
fault either bring it to the battle or
get out of the room I mean you're you're
tanking us over here right now I'm in
good shape because I eat at Italian
delies you're full of fish and and stuff
Ian Jesus Lou Lou you guys got one guns
got guns I gotun let's play 6 in
stronger shut
up stop you're and see what it you look
God you're literally like a you're like
a little rat I'm
aare
Focus God you're not in a mazeed trying
to get out of it right now just take a
breath yeah I'm in a maze of insults
that I'm trying to you guys have one
bread Ry it's a delicious it's it's a
high level bread it BR the bread so much
to the table but you got one bread you
got one bread what do you got and you
got three meats you put on that bread
brisket which is worthless pastrami
which is sometimes good and corn beef
which is a home run you're skipping chop
liver you're skipping
tongue disgusting and more disgusting
you mean chop Li tongue chop Li's Pate
you don't like Pate no Pate is
disgusting I'm a human not a cat yeah
exactly
I don't know about that by the way by
the way chop liver by the way chop liver
P day I'm sorry you mean liver worst cuz
that's what it is it's not it's baloney
past it's literally Pate it's the same
as Pate Pate liver worst is a form of
Pate it's a same crap isn't it more
solidified liver liver worst it's gross
is I to some people sophisticated and
some people
aren't some people are Oscar Meyer and
some people aren't all meats are
available in Oscar Meer that's how you
know no that's that's what I was going
to say is that a good you cannot get
good pastrami if you don't go to the
right place it's artisanal you go to
cats's it's like you go to get pastrami
from the store it's not even going to
come close you go to get like a I got to
take out I got to take out a second
mortgage you for a
Brit you're fired up you go to get cap
any of those Italian Meats from a
regular from a Supermarket they're going
to taste pretty good P strama you got to
get it done right you know what I mean
it's brind it takes a while it's
seasoned yeah just like Jews it's
nitpicky hold on a second it's not good
enough here I got to go here it's
difficult annoying that's not true
that's not what you just said is not
true what you just said is not true it
is true you have to get if you want a
good like salami huge meat in amongst
the Italians and there's many versions
of salami there's the suat there's it's
not as good it's not there's gen what
there's
super there's cooked there's you know
salami Cotto there's a lot of different
kinds of salami that's true if you want
those right you got to go quality on
those you can't go buy a batch of Oscar
Meer Jenna with salami and go oh this is
great can you get I'm not knocking J
Oscar Meer I'm just saying it is what it
is the high end at the store at the
supermarket is pretty good of all those
meet you just said the high end hold on
the high end of the pastrami at the
store at the supermarket not even close
get if Deli not even close can I just
say the reason you think that is because
you got a pallet of a poodle you don't
know nothing you think the deli meat the
the meats at a grocery store even
compare to an Italian deli they do
you're insane but here's the thing go to
his shop and taste what he got and then
go to a Safeway and see what you get
thank you very much me but here's Lou
he's got a point he's got a point you're
talking about you're talking about B's
head versus things that are literally
imported from it's it's no contest when
I go in if I go into an Italian Shop
okay and I'm putting it in quotes
because the term is thrown around a
little too Loosely especially in parts
of New York much to my Italian
women but if I go into it who's a little
riter but if I go into it should I have
yelled it would that have been better I
like it yeah the uh the uh if if I go
into an Italian Shop and I see Bor head
uhhuh cuz it happens yes I walk out I'm
like I'm not here for that's not I can
get that at any Deli and go go give me
an Italian and it'll be that
respect and imported Italian Meats age
true age cheeses from Italy by the way
let's get into cheeses dude you guys got
Swiss that's all you got well it's like
traditionally there shouldn't be any
cheese in a Jewish deli so we're new to
the cheese technically you know what I
mean but I'm saying like it's that's
also too you're letting you're letting
religion enter the equation your delies
dude no we're not that's the cool thing
about it is that the modern Jewish deli
you can get ham you can get bacon you
can get all these things the modern but
what you are we time traveling to these
jewi talk about traditional Jewish I'm
saying you're just saying there's a lot
of Jewish jellies that don't have cheese
because you can't I'm saying cheese is
new here all right fair enough I don't
know contribute to the conversation
instead of talking about your arms if I
could get a word in edgewise with you
two caddy broads going back in just jump
in without scaming over go ahead
use your
words congrats on updating your
delicious food that now Jews can eat
this that doesn't make it better now
women can drive and Gaza and you see
what that place is like oh
boy doesn't make it a good spot all I'm
saying oh boy I'm on your
side now see why I have to
yell did not say no you say horrible
things with at with any volume you're
at it works and you don't understand why
it's not okay what are you talking he's
giggling he made a promo video at my bar
this all will have to be beled what I'm
about to say oh listen to this he made a
promo video at my bar where he gets
bartended and he's screaming [__] in the
face of a woman sitting at the bar I go
Ian I can't put this out he goes why
it's funny I go I can't have my bar in
the feed of our bar putting a video of a
man yelling [__] in a woman's face do
you understand how you can't do that
when you're marketing a business give
the it wasn't just me yelling [__] I was
doing [__] puns and I it wasn't pck you
said I don't come down to where you work
and tell you how to suck five [__]
because a porn star got on me that I
didn't know how to make a drink I
thought you got honey cuz you didn't
know how to suck a [__] and you could
suck a mean one I'm sucking guys [__]
all righten talk I'll make their their
wieners come in a
heartbeat now it's a lot of
bleeps it's a lot of said weers I said
we no no no come oh yeah now that's now
that's got to get bleeped I mean what
are we doing this Zuckerberg Overlord K
what no that was anti-semitic Ian you
have to understand something first of
all when the thing was funny and he goes
but the children come to my restaurant
restaurant it's
a it's a
bar and and and thank you please tell me
about my own business we can we can
watch more on Tik Tok but I can't take
explain me about to me my own business
as you rode away from it that night
gleeful on your tricycle cuz you made
$54 explain to me how to run a business
I made close to a 100 and I tipped out
the bar staff and they told me you
should have they made half of your
drinks Ian I made everything except for
the difficult
ones he made so many comedy drinks that
I had to be like Ian stop making funny
drinks we're losing like fists of
alcohol back here we're losing like
bottles of alcohol cuz you're making
like zany like mixtures of pickle juice
and whiskey I'm like stop please
somebody has her a margarita and I was
like okay here's Whiskey and a thing
with the Sal which is why we had the
real bartender there to make the real
people got a kick out of it and I'll
tell you this right now two people were
to show last night and they go we were
there when of you bartending to Joey Ros
we loved how you didn't know how to make
the drinks and you were better at it
than Joe their word's not mine now which
Del's better let's get back to Hot Topic
listen okay here's the thing Italian
deli versus Jewish deli we going get
back to it
come
on we're on the same side salty salty
salty salty you're a you're a a shell of
a
man listen I know am I arguing it uh
speaking of shells another thing you're
not going to find a Jewish deli
shellfish you're going to find that in
Italian deli you're going to find some
nice shrimp you know uh are you oh
Italian delies I'll have see this's what
I like about Italian delies okay uhhuh
uh the there's a variety in them that a
Jewish deli I like Jewish delies hold on
listen to me listen to me just listen to
me Lou and you know this is true and Ian
back me up on this there is a variety in
an Italian deli that you don't get at a
Jewish deli and I will explain what that
is please it's twofold the first part is
just the cuisine itself there's going to
be breaded chicken cutlet there's going
to be chicken parm there's going to be
meatballs there's going to be sausage
and peppers there's going to be some
pasta dishes there's going to be cold
salads there's going to be you said
shrimp whatever there will often be a
seafood salad there will often be a
pasta with seafood in it a fra Alo
whatever they'll do different specials
for the day uh of of Cuisine type dishes
that's not even touching yet the
sandwiches which go far and wide and and
and all and whatever right hold on hold
on let me just so many objection hold on
hold on hold on let me just finish this
thought let me just finish this thought
sandwich comos are endless yes let me
finish the second part though I remember
you told me to jump in but you no no no
I want you to get behind all this whole
point I want you get behind this whole
point cuz this is a good point the
second part of it is yes the dry goods
part a good Italian deli Italian Shop
they've got shelves of Jarred Peppers
Jarred pickled mushrooms pickled
eggplant whatever it is pasta whatever
you can buy a lot of them have Frozen
stuff here's our gravy frozen here's our
meatballs Frozen here's fresh pasta that
we we made but it's frozen in case you
want to take it's like a grocery store
from your
na but that's exactly Jewish doesn't
have any of that yeah because the Jewish
deli evolved into a restaurant and the
Italian deli is still an old world
marketplace and that's not what you're
there for you're there for food hold on
on the variety is crazy I don't know how
long all that stuff's been in that
fridge it's been there for days who
knows how long it's been there the the
variety of sandwiches the variety of
sandwiches this kind of ham again this
kind of ham this kind of ham ham and ham
ham and ham and ham just different kind
of
ham the ham argument Lou the ham
argument is you're talking
about that's not not a good
argument Bara I'm talking yeah let him
no let him you got you got you know
what's a what's like an Italian combo
sandwich it's just different kinds of
pork is what I'm saying like right pork
is a different term than ham all right
so saying it's a salty salty meat on a
salty meat on a salty meat on a salty
let me tell you why there's nothing
wrong with a pork an all pork sandwich
it well just five different kinds of
pork I can't taste the different pork
it's not making anything happen that's
absolutely not true let me tell you why
and it's why I'm fascinated by the pig
as an animal and it's Pro it's providing
of meat to us folks did you know that
poor sleep can cause uh things like
weight gain uh mood issues poor mental
health uh lower productivity I knew
about some of that stuff I didn't know
about all of it um and I know that sleep
is important but I didn't know how much
of a negative effect poor sleep could
actually have on me and uh or or have on
any one of us uh sleeping less than six
to seven hours per night is actually
linked to reduced white blood cell count
uh and white blood cells protect our
body against you know illness and
getting sick and whatever and you know I
trust me I'm somebody that uh sleep as I
get older especially plays a very very
important part in my life and I see the
after effects if I'm not getting the
right amount of sleep and I see the
effects if I am getting the right amount
of sleep but in any case I'm talking
about all of this because beam a taste
bud sponsor is here to help uh and let
me tell you what beam wants to do today
listeners will get a special discount on
beams dream powder which is their
bestselling healthy hot cocoa for sleep
sleep and it has no added sugar which I
love now available also in delicious
seasonal flavors like cinnamon cacao sea
salt caramel and white chocolate
peppermint better sleep has never tasted
better I love this I love that they're
making a drink that helps you sleep and
it's delicious it's almost like you're
knocking out the late night snack and
the uh the uh uh steps to have a proper
night sleep and one Fell Swoop which is
nice uh a recent clinical study revealed
that dream helps 93% of users wake up
feeling more refreshed and 93% reported
that dream helped them get a more
restful nights sleep so if you want to
try beam's bestselling dream powder take
advantage of their biggest sale of the
year and get up to 50% off for a limited
time when you go to shop
beam.com that's shop beam
beam.com tastebuds that's shop
beam.com tastebuds for 50% off today
folks this episode of taste buds is
sponsored by better help uh I am a huge
advocate of better help uh I love better
help and I use better help uh I think
they're just providing a truly truly
great service uh in in an Department
that so many of us need some assistance
with in life uh here's the thing
uh this time of year and can be a lot
life can be a lot in general General but
this time of year in particular can be a
lot and it's actually quite natural to
feel some sadness or anxiety about that
whether you're recognizing that that's
where it's coming from or not uh adding
something new and positive to your life
can counteract some of those feelings
and for me therapy is a bright spot uh
amid amidst all the the stress and and
the chaos and everything else therapy
really helps me it it gives me something
to look forward to it helps me feel
grounded and it gives me the tools that
I need to manage everything that's going
on period um I have benefited greatly
from therapy uh especially during times
like this where life sort of kicks into
high gear and I need a little help in
feeling like the gas pedal isn't pressed
all the way to the floor that's really
really where therapy has assisted me
great lately so if you're thinking about
starting therapy for the first time or
maybe starting it up again give better
help a try it's entirely done online
it's designed to be convenient and
flexible and it's suited for your
schedule you fill out a brief
questionnaire and then you get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge that's huge uh anyway
find your bright spot this season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com
tastebuds and you're going to get 10%
off your first month that's
betterhelp.com tastebuds go there today
to get 10% off your first month
betterhelp
hp.com tastebuds the pig is the only
animal that provides several different
types of tasting Meats Stak can you can
have a better cut versus a better cut
but beef tastes like beef more or less
chicken there's a difference between
white meat and dark meat but chicken is
chicken turkeyy is the same thing the
peg it is providing you with a pork rib
tastes so different from a slice of ham
salami tastes so different gen with
salami tastes so different from sausage
there people are doing things with the
pig and giving it flavors that are so
vastly different it sounds like the pig
is doing the work whereas we are
actually doing the work to the beef but
also a corn versus a pastrami that's a
world of difference you're letting the
pig's parts do the work for you you know
what I mean provides you with a podcast
for you to argue these different things
and we thank you for that but wait a
minute the the the the you keep saying
this thing you keep saying this thing
about you the Jewish deli evolved into a
restaurant I love a corn beef sandwich
but dude I got to tell you if I want a
corn beef sandwich I don't want a
restaurant I want a deli if I want to
you want to eat in an alley like a or
you want to sit down but if I want a
restaurant I'll go to a damn restaurant
that's what a deli is okay but if I'm
going to a but but my point is I'm going
to an Italian deli and I've got all
these other options to pick whatever the
hell I want for launch
or you want buy a canned good and a
wheel of cheese and eat here the other
thing I don't like Lou Lou here's the
other thing I don't like that if I want
to if I want to get some of the stuff
from the Italian deli and say I want to
take some stuff home maybe make my own
thing this week I can do it affordably
every Jewish deli I go to when I want to
get a pound of corn beef they're like
that'll be $36 you're like what may CRA
want to do it I mean it's do it yourself
then you want you're [__] it's a deli
builda bear why are you doing it
yourself I want I want it cooked times I
don't want to pay $32 for a sandwich and
you know that that's true the corn beef
and pami sandwiches are like upwards of
$30 but I think a good Italian Del is
pretty expensive too not nowhere near
that dude service you're paying for
service you sit down there's napkins
service an 80-year-old man that walks
around and goes you want the pickle you
want the pickle that's good I love that
that's part of the experience May ience
okay and the Italian guy with the pencil
going hey but what can I do that's
that's experience true that is true so
my point is I want to sit down paying
for a booth cats is you walk to the
counter you take a ticket you do all of
the work yourself and the sandwich is 30
some expensive there's no doubt that's
expens now may I interject yes Lou said
something about what are you going to do
are you going to get the ingredients and
eat it in an alley do you know the joy
in getting a a a thing of cheese a bread
and meats and everything and arugula and
arugula yeah no go ahead finish this I'm
with you go L and taking it to the park
on a blanket sitting with friends and
you make your own sandwiches and you eat
there together but try getting a thing
of pastrami and rye and slapping it on a
thing it's not the same O Used get food
to go you just don't you don't have good
about getting a sandwich and leaving to
your point if you want me to talk why am
I getting steam cuz I cuz he was talking
and then I started talking and then you
started talking again while I was
talking and thought it was that count of
a steamrolling the I mean it's
unbelievable said ing he climbs under a
car and goes why did you run me
over you know talk and I get insurance
money I was talking to his point oerson
when I when oakerson and I lived in the
same neighborhood we were neighbors he
would be like let's order from Sarge's
Deli we'll get delivery we'll get we'll
get a pound of patami we'll get a pound
of corn beef we get ryber what dude we
would order this it would be
$100 true and it's like this is this is
absurd man like it's not worth that much
money no it's not it's too expensive but
the price you're paying for is a better
Deli it's a better Deli and that's why
it cost more money better things cost
more here what I'd counter that with
Louie and again I love a I battled corn
beef on Ry on this podcast I forget what
I battled it against is one of the
greatest sandwiches of all
time dude all right what are you doing
yo
that was
cool he's got a big
sack what the [__] I didn't know it was
Ari until I was over there all I saw was
C and B we got to addit our words I had
nothing to do with that I did not know
that that was going to happen he did
that on his own that's very possible he
did that on his own are you sure I have
brothers I've grown up all right all
right that doesn't count as some
workplace we need help because there's
there's a hard time talking over each
other when it's someone's turn to talk
can you point your at them all right can
we can you shut be great this is this
place is going sideways
today are you coming in
yeah doesn't help that he looks homeless
now so it really looks like some random
homeless man just walked in here amaz
kid got a hog on him I was impressed by
the sa talking about pami talking about
some Meats salami huh woo I bet that's
like a pig it tastes different in each
part yeah the
uh it's so funny was I yelling yeah you
still are uh
he so wait what were we talking about it
doesn't matter I lost it it doesn't
matter what can I have one more argument
I there's one thing more go goe do your
last argument there's a classic you have
classic s sandwiches the pami the Reuben
is a classic sandwich Reuben's
disgusting that's crazy oh that's what I
going to and and there's no really
classic Italian sandwich are you kidding
me I would say the
sandwi hold on hold oning the Italian
sub which is just a salt bomb it has no
depth no levels and then the chicken
parm which is the most basic sandwich in
the world it's
basically it's like a child invented it
they want oh I want I want pizza chicken
please mama give me pizza chicken that's
what it is okay grow up real sandwich
real flavor like a like a a shired
Calico Lou cat Louie Louie there's no
classic Italian sandwiches step back
while I own this what's the name of the
sand let him be a Bubba back while I own
this and drop the mic step back while I
own this and drop the mic sausage and
peppers peppers and eggs you're naming
ingredients shut up sausage and pepper
oh it's the only 80 booths at the San
jaro Festival every single year that
Festival sucks those Peppers suck that
shit's all garbage where's the Jewish
Festival Deli thing we need a festival
never mind oh Joe oh Joe Jo Joo let's
hear it let's hear it let's hear it Joe
I need to hear it I need to hear it
sausage and peppers chicken parm gross
uh uh chicken
cutlet all those things suck all those
things suck and guess what yeah they're
named after the ingredients so you hear
it you know what's in the sandwich a
true famous sandwich has its own name I
got news for you I love a corn beef I
love a corn beef on rye every time I get
it halfway through it I'm like oh my God
I I got to take a nap I feel sick right
now it's too much it's so much fat have
you ever heard of Anthony and Son Panini
shop look at the
menu invented their their own sandwiches
it's not a universal Italians are
creative shout outs to Anon and Sons yes
uh like I do like Anthony and Sons yes
they're great and look I love SES and I
love the Jewish in New York but but I
just don't think they can compare it to
a Time the level the you get meals I
mean what Sebastian said is wrong the
other thing is you could eat there all
day if you wanted to stay there and take
a nap in the corner you got crazy
breakfast you got crazy lunch you got
you got lockas you got blindes you
got things all day you Nam lockas and
bles aren't specific Jewish delies yes
they are
go TOA then Lou could you get you're
going to need to work the levels hold on
could you get could you get three meals
at a Jewish deli could you do breakfast
lunch and dinner yeah you can go bagels
and locks at breakfast for example you
can go uh soup in and lotas or whatever
for uh for lunch and then you can go
corn beef sandwich for dinner let's just
say that those are the and then and then
a dessert day two re rinse and repeat
that's it next day your I would get lock
eggs and onions for breakfast or I would
get a but Italian deli Italian deli
dozens of breakfast options dozens of
Sandwich options what thez of breakfast
options at an Italian deli I would never
go to Italian deli for breakfast you
would go to Italian deli for breakfast
oh dude we've only we only created the
the bacon egg and cheese the egg and
cheese on a roll created the bacon egg
and cheese that's all New York it wasn't
a Jewish deli putting pork and dairy
together a roll but I I don't I really I
find that hard to believe that bacon egg
and cheese is anti go go to a corner in
New York that's run by Italian Guys and
tell me if they got a bacon egg and
cheese I get my bacon and cheese from
Arabs that's who makes them for me all
right all I know all I know them all I
know is if you want to look at which one
is better look at the people who are
eating it look at how many fat Italians
there are because they're wellfed they
they want to do cat f cats's is on the
list when you come to New York you go to
cat's it is overpriced oh big do you go
to what Italian deli do you go to when
don't the Disney storees on the list the
cats is being on the list is like saying
Best Buy is on the list
in daughters is delicious cat's is
deliciouso shut down cats's is not
delicious cats's corn beef is dry and
their pastrami is fine if you dress it
up with enough Russian dressing and
mustard it's a solid sandwich but you
will pay $36 for it a bit of a tourist
trap by now by ad it is but I'm just
saying I'm just saying there's no
Italian deli that has that kind of look
you want Italian food you're going to go
to a restaurant you're going to get the
pizza it's delicious are you going to go
out of your way to find an Italian deli
yes I don't know if I don't know if
you're going to do that dude I went to
an Italian Shop in uh in uh or sandwich
joint in uh it was called Dave's um I'm
sorry Bob's Bob something Deli Bob's
Haven Deli it's it's down near
Phoenixville I went to that place uh
recently and dude it was Unreal you went
in and all they do is pizza Stromboli
Italian sandwiches sounds like you went
to a pizza shop dude it it's not a pizza
shop it's sounds like you went to a
pizza shop and not a deli it's not a
pizza it's a place that is pizza
strolean it's not a pizza shop they
don't have the slice out should stay in
their Lane serve pizza and pasta and
leave the deli we got to go to the
phones we got to go to the phones all
right we got to go to the phones Ryan
says both absolutely amazing went to the
Jewish deli in Chicago and it was
phenomenal uh Nick says I know you guys
are from NYC but have you traveled
through the country sometimes these
battles r on East Coast sorry we're not
arguing garbage play Trash Can andester
he's not wrong but he's not right there
are plenty of places now in the midwest
that have great they're great Jewish
delies and great Italian I've gone on
the road many times so that's you get so
much more variety of the Jewish deli but
both are you leave happy and full I you
see that guy by Connor Lee read that
Joey put slic of capaco on my eyes at
the spa and paint my nails with balsamic
reduction Italian deli all day baby all
yeah if I'm trying to get a good meal
Italian deli if I'm looking for a good
deal shout out to those JDS that's not
true it's the opposite JD is a bad deal
but it's just great sandwich can can I
make can I make one argument real quick
well yeah would the a whole new thing
though would The Sopranos be the same
without Italian deli meats so much of
that show you lost me there I hate
that's my le I hate that part of the
show so much what I think it's idiotic
you you're a fool him repeatedly
I can't stand it I can't stand it and
and it wouldn't that wouldn't exist
without Italian delies uh Deli is short
for delicat tessent which is a German
word brought here by German Jewish
people so I'm going to have to vote for
Jewish all right
nerd guess this is only for New Yorkers
no it's not Ben they're Italian and
Jewish places across the I hate when
people make a comment like that just
because their neighborhood doesn't have
this yes sorry that uh uh uh pot Town
Pennsylvania or wherever the hell you
live didn't have both of these options
readily available for
you and by the way potown does have
these options after this battle are we
going to see a reband to Joey Rosen
that's funny that's great a tan quisine
is King even a cold cut yes a good
pastrami on Ryan KES and some Kos on
this dude I don't know which way this is
going to go pimp let's go to the can I
can I say one more thing no you have
cooler name you have cooler nicknames
for m can I say it and then I'm going to
do it anyway who are You My Mother you
asked a question I said no and you did
it anyway yeah but you didn't let me
talking up all I'm saying is you get
cooler nicknames for Mob guys from
Italian deli stuff than you do wow what
a great Point thank God you said this
hey W hey watch out for Jimmy capol oh
what are you gonna be oh we need to
watch out for Murray pastrami that
sounds cool yeah right it made me laugh
in the end cuz you got loud and it got
funny all right listen we're going to
the vote whoever plug whatever you got
to plug now and whoever loses or sorry
whoever wins says the other guy I still
love you and then the you have to say I
love you too that's how the show ends so
get your plug out of the way and then
we'll do the vote okay uh watch my new
special on uh it's on YouTube it's
called present tense uh look me up it's
l i s k TZ check out the special and if
you like it please share it with your
friends check out Louis Special Lou
you're great we're busting shops today
but you're great you're very funny I've
known you from the beginning I think we
did new faces we new fa together like
2005 I've known Louie my entire ride in
this business I'm I'm glad to see your
that we're both still some of the guys
still doing it some of those guys
disappeared yeah some of them are are no
longer with us I'm glad you're not one
of them I'm glad you're still with us
and you're great man thank Joe loves you
so much that one time at the stand he
was so drunk yelling at me Louie catch
Louie catch you too good to talk to me
Lou cats so he sees you everywhere he
goes I was that really yeah oh yeah I
thought you were Lou Kat at the old
stand yeah and then you were talking to
someone you're like you can't even
[__] say hi to me they're like that's
not Lou Joe that's weird that sounds
exactly like
me uh do you have any plugs yes I'm
taping my first special Sunday December
3rd New York City The Cutting Room em
finance.com for tickets two show 7 9:30
it'd be amazing if you guys were there
people from taste buds and hey babe and
no press they come out to shows I can't
thank you enough I I I'm so excited
December 3rd Sunday Ean finance.com for
tickets Bean Ian with Jordan patreon.com
beanan Pond Ian's awesome too I'm so
happy you're doing your first special
buddy remember when you were new and
kicking around the city so you brother
congrats man go out to see Louis I sorry
watch Louis Special and go out to see
Ian tape his uh all right folks Humble
Pie time let's see who won this thing
pimp hovers over Italian deli that could
holy
[__] what is oh my god wow
81.5% in favor of Italian deli Jewish
deli coming in 18.5 dude I didn't think
it was going to be like a what's
interesting is 81.5 18.5 you can switch
them around and it's the same which
means we're all equal and we all love
each other the med the media is
controlling us somebody's watching right
now I think this proves anti-Semitism is
that's what I think I think it proves
you have a lot of Italians
who thank you I honestly I feel
uncomfortable the Jewish lost this badly
with all that's going on in the world
right now it's making me very
uncomfortable I'm happy cuz it's another
win on my belt for the show but right
now it's making me that should be split
and I think it's a little I I I think
that's wild maybe people voted that way
cuz they are watching the show and they
just dis like you no they're think they
can't see what's happening right now go
along with it oh this no it's Prett
anyway Lou we still love you I love you
too thank best I love you Lou and I
spend so much time together and did you
hear when I explained how the podcast
ends it's over now stop
talking taste buds they coming to the
mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools going to fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they
coming to the